le conseil général de seine saint denis
organise ce soir une grande fête
populaire dans le parc de la courneuve
un spectacle qui permettra d'animer
cette exceptionnelle espace vert situé
en bordure de l'autoroute du nord le
parc paysager départemental de la
courneuve avec ses 200 hectares ouverts
depuis neuf ans au public est beaucoup
plus qu'un îlot de verdure dans un coin
de banlieue qui en aurait bien besoin
car il s'agit d'un parc créé de main
d'homme à partir de rien la première
tranche de travaux portant sur 136
hectares a débuté en 1960 pour s'achever
à la fin de l'année 1969 livrant au
public pour ses loisirs surface gazonnée
sous bois et aires de jeux mais tout
cela ne s'est pas fait sans difficulté
au début nous avons eu d'autant plus de
problèmes que nous étions les seuls à
financer une telle réalisation
et ensuite il y a peu de temps pour
l'étrange qui en suivit celle où se
trouvent les plans d'eau maintenant nous
avons reçu une aide de la part de l'
agence régionale d espaces verts
en principe nous devrions avoir une aide
pour la poursuite de l'extension du parc
est l'exemple que nous avons donnée avec
la réalisation de cet équipement son
extension nous permet de considérer
qu'après tout on peut aller plus loin
dans l'amélioration des espaces verts
dans le département de la
seine-saint-denis d'autant que habite
dans ce département des gens qui
travaillent qui font beaucoup d'efforts
qui ont besoin surtout eu bon besoin
d'un environnement qui correspond à
l'effort de travail l'effort de création
qu'ils font la seconde tranche d'environ
200 hectares a été mise en chantier à
partir de 1974
une première étape de 60 hectares a déjà
été réalisée elle comprend les lacs le
relief du belvédère une roseraie de 35
mille roses et la vallée des fleurs qui
hession leur floraison de mars à
novembre terminer ce seront 450 hectares
que le parc de la courneuve mettra à la
disposition des habitants la seine saint
denis